there's a new ad for the norwegian
postal service
that
i'm not sure
really how it was promoting the postal
service
all i know is that it turned santa
gay
so you see a guy
he's waiting in his nice christmasy
living room
here we go some packages from the postal
service i guess merry christmas
he walks back into the living room
there's santa
yeah
well i arranged some health care
so i can be with you says santa
and then there's this guy and he's
looking at santa in a kind of strange
way
[Music]
walks up to santa
and uh
are they gonna wait a second are they
no
not santa claus no no you don't need to
do this to santa claus to end
they okay and they kiss and santa kisses
them okay this
i think
we don't need to see santa make again i
saw daddy kissing sandwich we don't we
don't need
now you've got a frequent the norwegian
postal service
a lot of people are looking at this ad
and saying hey man you know i'm not i'm
no homophobe but uh
we don't need to make everything gay do
we blake masters who's running for the
senate from arizona he said this about
superman they're turning superman gay
now he said you know not everything has
to be gay but the thing is
it does actually everything does have to
be gay
this is the way
it gets right back to the notre dame
point it gets right back to this
religious conflict okay
there is going to be
a sexual standard every society is going
to have one and they're going to say
some
this is not true just of sex it's true
of everything they're going to say some
things are good to do and some things
are bad to do some behavior is good some
behavior is bad some speech is good some
some speech is bad and
and that's especially true when it comes
to sex because sex is so important to
our human nature and so if the left is
going to totally transform our sexual
ethic then everything needs to follow
the new rules
christmas christmas time is near time
for toys and time for cheer you've got
all these wonderful memories of
christmases thanksgivings all the
wonderful memories and they're sitting
in a box you're sitting in a box
somewhere degrading either they're at
risk of fire or flood or just old father
time which degrades your pictures your
cassettes your old movies legacy box
will help you preserve them the way it
works you send in all your old media the
pictures and the movies and all of it
you send it in to legacy box they will
hand digitize everything
they will then put it on a thumb drive
or the cloud or a dvd or some
combination thereof and then you will
have those memories forever and old
father time ain't going to stop them and
the floods and the fires ain't going to
stop them either these are irreplaceable
sentimental memories do not be like me i
actually lost some pictures and i
thought they were gone forever
fortunately i found some more
immediately sent them into legacy box
legacy box is giving our listeners the
best deal of the year right now for
their black friday event go to
legacybox.com knowles canadas to save 65
with limited qual quantities ready to
ship this deal will go fast that's
legacybox.com
knowles you will get a whopping 65 off
legacybox.com
knowles the norwegians turned santa
gay and they they sort of have to
they they they have to superman has to
go gay and that
the the i think the libertarian idea is
look
we don't really need any rules you just
you do you i'll do me you don't you
don't push your views on me and i won't
push my views on you and we'll all just
get along but that's not how society
works society has views and so
if
if we live in a society that like our
traditional society which said that sex
has a purpose to quote the great
philosopher nor macdonald sex is a
filthy as shameful thing that's
obviously only meant for procreation if
if we live in a world that views
sex as having a purpose then that is
what sex is going to be geared toward
okay and there are going to be
unusual kind of desires and activities
outside of that and those activities and
desires will probably be tolerated but
they won't they won't be celebrated and
they won't that won't be seen as the end
of sex and marriage will be encouraged
and families will be encouraged and that
was the way our civilization worked for
at least a thousand years more than that
more than a thousand years
now since
certainly since the 1960s the purpose of
sex has not been
understood to be procreation
it's not the human person is not seen to
have a a
definite end you know a tea loss a
purpose of of our lives
it has been thought that the point is
just to get pleasure just to kind of
feel good if it feels good do it and so
in that world
that's that's the kind of standard
that's going to be encouraged and so for
i mean we're kind of joking about gay
santa here but that is going to be the
case
for everything and you're going to have
to make a decision are you going to
give in
to that zeitgeist are you going to give
in to the spirit of the age and just let
secularism and leftism roll over your
whole culture or are you going to stand
up and say no actually you shouldn't do
certain things you shouldn't behave in
certain ways you shouldn't you shouldn't
be taught certain things
we're going we're going to set the
standards ourselves i'm glad you like
that clip now hold on before you go
ring the bell please please that'd be
great ring the bell subscribe you
theoretically will get notifications to
these videos and if our pals at big tech
don't want you to you definitely should
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitch or google play wherever you get
your audio podcast subscribe for free to
the michael knowles show leave a five
star review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you